as the Panama papers revelations of
industrial scale tax avoidance widen and
deepen parliament has its chance to
voice its position and shape Europe's
response and your opportunity for some m
eps to put in place global rules on top
of existing fiscal evasion measures la
primera cosa que tenemos que Ferris
pedir una cumbrae con naciones unidas y
con hace de antes de finalize our este
año para concrete are tres cosas primera
que es para ESO fiscal una definition
como para todo el mundo dos una lista de
Paraiso fiscal en el mundo tres San
Fiona's Paris auspices Parliament is
fighting tax avoidance on several fronts
the temporary special committee on tanks
set up after last year's lux leak
scandal has been extended you anti-money
laundering legislation was toughened by
Parliament making some avoidance
vehicles more transparent m eps are also
demanding tax good governance clauses in
international agreements and have pushed
for country-by-country corporate tax
reporting chingari from Kirkuk does TC I
tub8 the bilayer of crystal converter
the atul feel of a beetle missed key
look on Jada's can tie the attack
warmest black sheet he left Unser's
parliamentary she's Parliament thus to
assets and hospice at langham father for
the moment m eps are debating the Panama
papers after which the Commission is to
present a statement on tax transparency